yes finally after all these years we
have found the blacksmith
turns out the blacksmith was in here
all along hey welcome to fantasy
blacksmith a blacksmith simulator
now there's another better rated blacks
get rid of this music no put in our own
music we will put in
epic fantasy music not this droll
there's another better rated
fantasy blacksmith game called my little
blacksmith shop
and it is not much better rated
but it's cutesy and adorable and i feel
like that's not indicative of a real
blacksmith simulator
i want there to be pressure i want there
to be pressure to perform
i want there to be stakes because if you
don't arm enough soldiers in this war
you will die because the enemy will win
and they will come rampaging over the
hills and they will kill you
slot one name my character the
blacksmith
bam i want to be the best blacksmith
in these lands i need to be at the top
of the list
it will not be easy i will have to
comprehend blacksmithing and also mining
enchantment damask
craft and runic magic that one's fine
and one day i will become the best and
the most famous blacksmith
right no one will ever lose me again oh
my god okay speed through this section
i'm going to actually try to learn this
because i don't want to just
fuss around even though i'm probably
going to be futzing around
before you go to the mines i'm going to
the mines
usually people provide the blacksmith
but i guess i'm on my own here so
tiddly filly d alchemist to make
damascus steal
you need to buy a metal box
oh it's got a plug a power plug in there
that's convenient you can add a magical
effect to the weapon on the rune table
you'd cast a spell you put the crystal
as well as this
crystal he didn't say anything about it
chris okay whatever alter
coke
a stove for eating call to make coke
i prefer pepsi fantasy blacksmith is a
magically enhanced realistic blacksmith
simulator in which you have to create
and sell weapons it's time to make your
dream sword
okay let's just get familiarized with
the location it's really dark you'd
think for a place with a lot of fire and
heat it'd be a little
brighter but no it's absolutely not okay
make a drop make it dry
map village forge whoa
okay do it do i need bro no i mine
bronze i'ma make my own bronze that's a
nice meat thermometer wow
didn't know they had this back in the
day all right i need a pickaxe cause i
gotta go mining i'm not gonna spend all
my money
okay therma wow it's made of wood that
seems to be a problem
do i not have one do i need to buy one i
probably need to buy one right can i get
a torch should be nice use torch and
mines
that sounds good do i have a pickaxe i
don't
okay cart delivery time
who did that oh my god
hello torch great oh perfect do i have a
pickaxe
anywhere pickaxe what is oh colbot take
the cool box and
throw it into the furnace okay but why
now
why would i do that now i don't see a
pickaxe anywhere but the torch is nice
i'm just gonna go down and hope there's
one there can i
oh that's not what i thought it was
gonna be but
okay does this go down yeah let's go
down like
yeah there we go oh it's
[Music]
i have to dig through here okay so
there's gotta be a pickaxe somewhere
here
hello may i escape my leash ow
stairs you could use an inner guard rail
doth bequeath me with a pickaxe
was i supposed to put all the coil in
why why are you still here
okay let me take it check its
temperature okay this this sermon member
don't do nothing
press g to close it don't the funny
thing is it really don't
restart the blacks hang on
press and tap see ah interesting okay
why to see abilities you can level up
okay i should listen to it
always follow the arrows and make your
first sword
easy use a map to buy bronze ingot and
make a sword draft
okay bronze ingot
oh oh oh
interesting a bulbous
[Laughter]
let's do basic i'm i'm not here to
really uh
mix up the recipe here bulbous and uh
you know we could go a little decorative
here let's go bulbous
what is this what did i do okay either
way i made this i'm not gonna do
anything else i'm gonna
add
okay iron oak
and bronze okay
got it cart buy
take a cool box and throw okay i should
have fought ben following the tutorial
and i
i wasn't do i do more than that do i do
more than
okay put the ingot in the furnace okay
there's t
name bronze okay use the bellows to
overcome
700 degrees threshold take the
thermometer and measure the ingot
temperature
okay measure
measuring it temperature it's not
measuring i don't think it's in
too hot need tongs uh well
uh but how do i
how do i i really wish i could measure
something oh tongs i have tongues
okay blam
how how measure measure how measure i'm
click
measure please don't leave me now
tutorial tutorial
or measure but bam i'm doing it
why oh my god some tells me this wasn't
hot enough
it just says to check heat you need use
thermometer how
how oh that is hot okay set ingot on and
sure okay press one
or q to hide e okay we're gonna we're
just going for it
yeah yeah this looks good this looks
good
yeah this is looking good looking real
it's cooling i gotta hurry oh no
oh no oh no it's really ticking shape
man this is the whole experience huh
which is what i wanted this is what i
paid for okay let's lump it up
get these lumps out of here it seems
like it might have cooled too much
okay put the ingot yeah okay okay we
gotta put it back
okay all right this is this is truth
take thermometer and measure
how how you keep saying do this
but you never say how how
o'clock how how
what what what i have to point what
what am i point what oh you have to
point it at the
not that
where's my really wang on it button oh
my god this thing with the heat
good got you know if i swung faster
maybe i wouldn't have too much of a
problem with the heating reheating it's
heating up
getting there getting there i don't know
what temp i'm going for here so i'm just
kind of trying i'm kind of yeah that's
good
okay get to work well go go no go no no
go go go okay
yeah yeah almost done
getting close oh no no okay
can't do too much can't do too much this
is gonna be a perfect there's gonna be a
goddamn
there's gonna be a goddamn beautiful
sword okay come on go go go go
i could just do it by the color alone
you know so but it's about 900
is what it's looking for i think get
that
up there right up there right up there
get that come on you're close you're
close
you close yes the answer is yes no
no bad what do you mean bad okay
it's done i guess it's time to temper it
sure uh
sure i bad bad you're bad you're bad
you're bad
anything here what uh uh what did i do
am i running low on coal or something i
mean you know
i is there a problem i'm not not enough
cold
more coal okay that's better that's
better that's better okay so
i remember it saying there was something
important
and then you have one second when the
flames go out that's right
oh got it nailed it perfect didn't i did
i just
did i temper it i tempered it it's
tempered skip tutorial let's just
go on with our life and i can't sharpen
do i sharpen it
grind what
i did it okay it still wants me to
temper you goddamn [ __ ]
i don't understand what do you want from
me game what do you want
what do you want from me game what do
you want
okay i gotta go do goal i gotta go
back and do it all over again
great let's just try a different the the
better
blacksmith okay we're gonna make
the new we're gonna make forge and then
we're gonna make
a bulbous tip out of iron we're gonna
make a nice
grip out of oak we're gonna make a
pommel out of bronze do we have we don't
have iron
that's a that's a problem okay not a big
fat blade we're gonna
make a skinny blade bye done
this furnace okay
bam bam okay this is a good one this is
a good one
now it's time to temper the sword it
must be hot
okay it must be hot so
heat it okay and then
click it don't exactly
look good did i do it i don't understand
it's not
done clearly it's not done
look i don't care if this whole thing's
bad it's clearly not done
there's some doneness there we go
okay now it's doneness
looks hot to me why does this work
after forging and tempering the blade
you'll need to cool it okay i did that
now i'm gonna sharpen it
ah i don't know man
sure seth oh now you'll let me you just
didn't
oh now we're doing it set the handle
parts on the
assembly table okay
get rid of this stupid thing where's the
assembly table oh
this is the assembly table okay the yeah
okay all right i
i feel this i feel this i'm feeling it
i'm feeling it
i'm feeling it i'm feeling this and
now the blade put it here
and wap boosky oh what
no what what
next i did it i guess oh
god here we go
sure glad that's deterministic
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
seen in my life
total that's so stupid i have a sword
i'm gonna sell it
oh someone's at the door hey you wanna
buy hey
what's up what's up can you sharpen my
sword okay
gamble you know whoa i'm here now
i did it i'm the best thank you master
goodbye
bye bye no melted not good
good very good cheap that didn't cost me
500 gold i'm just gonna sell it i guess
i'm on my own now
there we go okay i did my first sword
now what have i been aban i've been
abandoned
hello map village please
i want any sort of pickaxe for mining
i thought that was kind of it so i
didn't have to buy it all the time
but you know i'll just do another one
okay
let's do it again let's do it again
let's do that again
i mean let's do it again because i i
think i can do better than that
okay here we go pop that in there so i
guess from
now on i'm just a blacksmith and uh this
is my job
and uh i just kind of do my job and uh
i don't worry too much about nothing so
i think the trick is just when it starts
to get orange is when i should take it
out
because obviously i was doing it too
much last time and that was no good for
anybody
especially my customers and especially
the sword
because the sword is melted i don't like
this just you'll hold up if you want to
buy a source
curvy melted thing but it was my first
attempt and i'm very proud of it so i'm
just going to aim for 800 each time
just about that moderate medium rare
orangish
okay there we go let's make it happen
captain what
you want where'd my hammer go do i have
a hammer
do i have a hammer do i have a hammer
there we go
okay bang
[Applause]
well i guess i lost my hammer i guess
that's what's happened
guys i lost my hammer real tragedy kind
of hard to do the blacksmithing thing
if i don't have my is it done let's
temper this bad boy i guess
sure
yep and cool it cool good good great
great great
okay great i can't grab a lost to the
void it is
lost it is lost you know aha i got it
all right let's grind it well funny
about that it doesn't seem to want to
you know you know it seems like uh
almost like it don't work
quite right it almost seemed like it
don't do the work
you know what i'm going to the other
blacksmithing game
because i am sick of that
[ __ ] i just want to see if this one
is better because if it is
then my blacksmithing experience can
truly come to fruition
new uh i don't even need the tutorial
excuse act let's see the tutorial okay
oh what oh hello hi hello hot
this is roblox ass blacksmiths whenever
you're ready step of the portal by
w-h-s-d
what why why where am i going i'm a
blacksmith
important in your journey to great we
learn anime
i don't want to learn i can't strafe
left it really is h i thought you were
just joking w-h-s-d
but no you were you were oh but i didn't
mean to do that
are you serious there's no way to change
movement oh here we go a
i've never played this game before so
why would it be
h hi yeah okay uh-huh yeah uh-huh
looking
okay i did it portal sure oh my god
oh my god hello grab the hammer
got it grabbed what did i just do
what wait what i
what what is this then what is this when
starting a new shop have a quick and
easy access to new stock is essential
during your first
first let's create a copper okay if you
look at this order form we can order
ingots grips and
guards one copper ingot and one
one-handed grip
okay coppering it
okay hello pick up that ingot hold right
click okay
okay go ahead and drop the heat that bad
boy up okay we'll do we'll do we'll do
will do with is so far so similar the
floor is a bellow
yeah grab the heated ingot with your
bare hands and follow me
this don't seem right place it
okay it's it's snapped
do i hit it
it's not even a satisfying thunk sound
metal selection menu what
z oh well i wish i could see what the
hell this
meant is there no audio here
just screw that i'm going to the other
game god god damn it i'm back you know
sorry i look baby i'm sorry i i wanted
to see if the other one was gonna be any
better but it turns out it really wasn't
none of these are good but you're the
only one good for me okay
hammer please exist now
yes okay hammer's back
shut up go away i have no bit i have no
swords
shut up i go away i don't have anything
okay you know what's good enough you
know what i'm not even worried about the
the small little bits
and bobs i'm not going to worry about
any of that because if i did that i
would be
here all day and i would never make any
money
and i'm not going to worry about ruining
this because i'm going to make the
perfect sword
a perfectly good enough sword a perfect
get back in your spot
you [ __ ] oh there's something about
putting out the fire when you're not
using it
i guess this is putting it okay there we
go yeah sure
okay we're cool and ready to rock
and then we grind it out and then we
spin the wheel
run
[Music]
okay really good stuff put the quality
sword in the quality hello
put the quality sword in the quality
sword
forge put it in the where'd my pommel go
where's my pommel pommel hello
oh did the pommel not make it in uh that
must be that must have been the issue
okay yeah now we're good okay now this
very bizarre
thing
hang on a minute
twist twist
twist okay good okay we've got a sword
hey
it's not bad this is definitely way
better hold on
it's definitely way better than the
others let's take a look
okay i he overheated it didn't mean to
ah damn it
not tempered what do you mean not
tempered hello god damn it what do you
mean not tempered
what do you mean not tempered i don't
know whatever i'm just selling it
i don't understand anything that you
want i found a new location new shops
and items now available
oh great i found it you know in my
basement i found it with my sixth sense
and i discovered it
by sending my ethereal form across the
cosmos
interior or smelter dice table
dice table dwarf shield what why anyone
got a pickaxe
so you got i uh
oh yeah uh-huh uh i wanna i just want a
mine that's all i've ever wanted
it's what i wanna do i also need more
coal oh
okay here we go got this got that got
this
got that okay okay really
close grip on those but you know it's
fine
okay here we go and so
was there another what what
what oh right mouse button right
okay
oh what the hell what the hell what the
fresh hell
what it what it this is an art
i found a pot oh my god i'm in the mine
do you mind
oh my god okay i found a pot
what you want to buy a jug it's gone
screw you what is
didn't i have an artifact spot here
here good great you know what
it's fine you know why it's fine
because it's fine i'm gonna make one
more sword
okay one more and it's going to be the
best
sword in the world i'm gonna put
everything into this
right everything i got is gonna be the
most fantastical
bay salt yes uh
grip oak absolutely uh
pommel bronze you know it what kind of
bulbous okay bulbous that
big in the middle and
skinny here but the tip whip blee wobbly
the tip is thickums no the tip is
thickems it's got that thick
tip this is going to be the greatest
sword that anyone
has ever ever ever
known done give that to me
and then we're gonna make our dreams
come true okay
pop her in
put these all in the thing this time not
some of them into weird spots but all of
them in the thing
okay i'm actually concentrating on this
i can't believe it but i'm really
try-harding this one i want to make a
good one just to know that i actually
have the capabilities to be a blacksmith
which was
oddly enough when i was a kid for some
reason i really wanted to be a
blacksmith
not a lie one more pass and then she's
good
the perfect sword the dragon slayer
the giant killer
hold on what what what is it
what is actually you know what go away
i'm in the middle of something i'm
making perfection here
all right so i'm gonna get it up to the
working temperature again
and then i'm gonna quench it because i
think my problem before was it was too
hot
for the tempering and then that's no
good okay
then bam when the flames go out
okay and then cool it and it should be
tempered
that's how tempering works i believe
excellent good
decent okay
okay that's okay it's not not the best
but it's okay put it there
okay so for the moment of truth
damn i think that was off okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay that's good
that's good 95 good i'll take 95.
it's probably like skills that you get
that makes this a little easier
baby keep it above 90 and i'm happy
now the twist
no yes
[Music]
perfect love it i'm the greatest ever
look at this beaut
look at this magnificent this
incredible this stunning sword
unlike anything that's a clock
sword shot he oh yeah
look at this beauty incarnate
look not temp why is it not
tempered what do you mean forge quality
very bad
what do you mean forge quality very bad
it's okay because this
is a goddamn good sword and i am waiting
what do you mean what is this
why is this upside down no
i get now why it's upside down look at
this beauty
i don't understand tempering because it
said as soon as the flames go out you
take it away and that's what i did
you heat it you take the heated blade
you put it in and boom
maybe i don't reheat it is that what i
no it said take the heated blade i don't
understand come on who wants to buy my
sword
buy one sword get one sword
customer can you
there you go
okay to the void with you oh
wow that was great good i don't even
have enough i hate
this was fantasy blacksmith or as i like
to call it blacksmith simulator all the
frustrations
of being a blacksmith wrapped up into a
beautiful package
you know the funny thing was as i was
getting into that
i was starting to enjoy it this game
obviously has a lot of bugs but
the nightmare of that was that other
game i prefer this
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you too dreamed of being a
blacksmith back in the day as you were a
child
working in the forge and hammering
things with a big hammer
and an apron write in the comments and
let me know your personal very deep
truth story and i will
compare mine to yours and we'll see
whose dream was bigger
and better so thank you and as always i
will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you